今天要分享的课程内容是游戏主题曲之创作
经验分享好
现在我们一样先来朗诵一首韵脚诗
这首韵脚诗叫恋诗法
这个诗是尸体的尸哦
不是诗歌的诗
感觉这有没有毛骨悚然的感觉
我在练私房里的断句跟分行
是一种极其媚俗的商
持续成立意淫的桂冠
也就不得不持续重复那些讨喜的妆
当简朴的拼图仪式被口耳相传成信仰
也就不必太压抑那些膜拜的香
唯有焚烧整座庙后的灰烬
看不出风格的形状
必须亲自分析检验那些细如尘埃般的意象
如此丝才开始具备实际的重量
他这种其实是反讽式
是反讽我自己的作品
因为我的作品的风格很鲜明
我指的是韵脚石
因此呢我在玩一种文字的游戏
那这种游戏呢创作者的本身就是我了然于胸
我怎么防风法呢
我在练书房里的断句跟分行
是一种极其媚俗的伤
极其媚俗
因为韵脚韵脚很媚俗哦
应该讨好你的听觉
所以是一种极其媚俗的伤
持续成立意淫的桂冠
也就不得不持续重复那些讨喜的妆
我把我的韵脚是化了妆
你知道吗
化了什么妆
化了韵脚的妆
文字行
今天很可口
很适合入味
就是吃进去你的思想里面
这个是我刻意安排的一个布局
所以这里面一再一再的反讽我自己的作品
当简朴的拼图仪式被口耳相传成信仰
这个信仰某种程度就是我韵脚的风格
也就不必太压抑
那些膜拜的香
就是别人觉得哇你的韵脚是好特别哦
这样子的风格在新诗的流派里面没有见过
我一再的反讽自己的作品
就是因为没见过
所以你觉得它独特
但是就我而言
那些是经过精心安排的文字节奏
唯有焚烧整座庙后的灰烬
看不出风格的形状
就说焚烧的意思是
你不晓得这首韵脚诗是我写的
不要先入为主
好像一个品牌
因为通常我们有时候会迷失一些物质的品牌
就好像哇这是某某品牌的包包
这是某某品牌的服饰
就好像它有价值感
因为你心里面会有一个价值
有些物件的价值是在心里面
你的心理价值
就好像有句话叫需要跟想要
通常我们日常生活需要的东西不多
三餐温饱有张床就可以睡
这个叫需要
但是你知道吗
在物质的需求上
想要的世界非常非常的大
我想要这个品牌
我想要这个包包
而不是我需要这个包包
我想要吃这个米其林的餐厅
而不是我需要吃这顿饭
这是非常巨大的一个分野
这也是品牌价值介入的一个缝隙跟空间
就是通常我们对物质的需求都是想要
而不是需要需要是很基本的生存需求
但是我们需要的世界很小
想要的世界无限的大
所以我才会写说唯有焚烧整座庙后的灰烬
看不出风格的形状
就是你不晓得这是我写的
不要先入为主
必须亲自分析检验
那些细如
陈默哀的意向只是说求或技巧
那这个是反讽思
是反讽我自己
但并不是说我写的不够好或韵脚式是不对的
一种写作风格
不是的
不是的好
最后一句如此丝才开始具备实际的重量
也就是说你觉得这首诗还不错
但是你不晓得是我写的
那你的先入为主已经去掉了
你的品牌迷思已经去掉了
你纯粹就作品论作品
这个很重要
所以我才说我有除去这些光环
你不晓得是谁写的
不晓得是我写的
你还觉得这首诗不错
那这首诗就具备了真正的文字重量
是这样子反讽而来的
在音乐圈呢有时候也会有这种状况
就说你已经知道这是谁的专辑
这是谁的歌了
你心里面会帮这个歌手加分
可能他之前的表现还不错
可能他之前的创作你觉得很优秀
也因此呢接下来他出来一个还可以的作品
你就觉得哇又有新作出现了
不又可以试听的想念了
因为你已经先入为主了
你已经知道这是谁的作品了
这是谁的创作了
你心里面暗暗的帮他加分
当然啦如果悬殊太大
作品的品质差距太大
你还会扣分
而且扣的非常的严重
接着我们分享的是我自己也很喜欢的作品
叫半兽人
这个作品是好多年前的一个游戏的主题曲
那这个游戏呢就是魔兽争霸
魔兽争霸三的中文主题曲
很遥远的记忆吧
很怀念的一个游戏吧
那游戏的画面很丰富
很精彩
就觉得我好过瘾哦
我居然我的创作可以跟游戏做结合
然后经由歌手的传唱
有一定的能见度
而这个能见度呢又回馈到自己的身上
觉得哇这样子的一个工作性质是自己的追求
没有错
第一段再也没有纯白的灵魂
自人类堕落为半兽人哇
好特别哦
纯白的灵魂
然后人类堕落成半兽人了
我开始使用第一人称记录眼前所有的发生
第二大段嗜血森林醒来的早晨
任何侵略都成为可能
我用古老的咒语重温吟唱灵魂序曲
寻根这首歌从头到ya同个韵脚
当初创作的时候其实没有限定说不能换韵脚
但是创作就是这样子
你写的顺就继续创作下去
像这样的主题性质的一个创作
针对性很明显
而且呢相对而言它的素材够多
我刚刚强调过的前一堂课反而好写
像这首半兽人也是我喜欢的一个电玩
也是我喜欢的题材
所以创作的当下
其实这首歌虽然意境很繁琐
很多画面感
但是我印象中好像就一天把它完成
因为对一个创作者而言
特别是音乐人
有时候一整天或者是半天好了
把一个完整的歌词或一首旋律去完成
而且几乎不用修改
这样子的几率其实没有
很常见
不到八个小时
我印象中好像一个下午
一个下午
因为题材是你感兴趣的
因为画面感很强
所以创作起来其实很流畅
那进入副歌前呢
我让大家听一段前奏
就会更有想象空间
有个音乐的辅助会加强你对文字世界的想象
所以呢我们来听一下它的前奏
能听到海浪的声音
那个是编曲
编曲后面加的
有没有感觉到好像有中土世界要出来
就像魔界
魔界里面的中土世界
很多种族
因为我很喜欢那种不同种族在存在一个空间感
然后相互不管是战争攻伐竞争啊
或者是生存那样子的世界很吸引我
所以这样子的题材创作上很过瘾
而且把它当作创作
而不是工作
是不是很有画面感
好的
那我们分享到这里
继续讲解下去
接下来进入副歌前的岛歌引导的导
刚刚前面是很大段的a n k a two
面对魔界的邪吻
不被污染的转身
维持纯白的象征
然后还原为人
这句话很重要
为什么要还原为人
因为我一开始提到自人类堕落为半兽人
就是你的磁性
要把前面的有些伏笔或铺成
把他拉回来
或者是做再一次的说明
再来我们就要进入副歌咯
让我们半兽人的灵魂翻滚
收起残忍回忆兽化的过程
又点了一次题目了
为什么呢
收起残忍回忆兽化的过程
因为半兽人在我的理解或铺陈中
它是人类转化的
所以在回忆兽化的过程
第二段副歌
让我们半兽人的眼神单纯而非贪婪着
永恒只对暴力忠诚
接下来我们继续介绍副歌
让我们半兽人的灵魂翻滚
这是记忆点
所以都没有改
停止愤恨永无止境的战争
我还是想把半兽人的血腥和暴力拉回来
让我们半兽人的眼神单纯
对远古存在的神
用谦卑的身份
这里面还是有一个最高位阶的神
所以半兽人在地表上如何的血腥
如何的暴力
你还是应该有谦卑的心
因为还有个最高的神
在这个位置在俯视你
看着你的所作所为
这个副歌我还是有做局部的调整
特别是低段
譬如像看让我们半兽人的灵魂翻滚
让我们半兽人的眼神单纯一个小变化
但是让我们半兽人这几句是没有改的
本来只有一次意思而已
就是让我们半兽人的灵魂翻滚
但我发现这个副歌唱了四遍
一直翻滚
很奇怪好吧
我让你的眼神单纯诶
好像有个语境的安排
然后又更丰富了
在最后面ending的结尾泪翻腾风
异常的冰冷
马蹄声让人睡不安稳
这个就很具备联想力
为什么只有战争才会有马蹄声
而且是狂乱的马蹄声
就是你夜里睡不安稳
好像有侵略者来了
好像别的种族要攻打过来了
所以这样子的用法是很有联想力的
你没有说战争
你没有受攻击
但是你用马蹄声来象征一个呼之欲出的攻击
跟暴力即将席卷而来
下面的歌词是我在等灵魂序曲完成
带领族人写下祈祷文
很明显这个我就是人类了
他在等灵魂序曲完成
好像有个重大的目标在集结
然后带领族人写下祈祷文
最后一段让我们半兽人的眼神
单纯对远古存在的神用谦卑的身份是重复唱
就是说我最后把谦卑的身份
对存在的神作为一个ending
一个结尾试图冲淡了这整首歌的暴力和血腥
你不能歌颂暴力吧
你不能赞扬血腥吧
毕竟我们还是人类的世界种子
它是电玩企业的一方
也不允许在歌词里面变成正义的一方
或战胜的一方
或永远压倒性的一方
创作上的人文关怀还是要有
但是遣词用你可以天马行空
给很多创意很饱满
很多意象
但最后的结尾
还是要把所有对人类的期望和慈悲把它拉回来
很多电影都是这样子
就是你看魔戒
不管是强兽人
半兽人多么的暴力
最后还是哈比人
哈比人等同于人类
还是人类获胜
这是戏剧的主轴
我不相信
从古至今有一个戏剧或舞台剧或者电影
纯粹的崇尚暴力
然后暴力的是获胜的一方
而且没有办法方案
人类永远被压迫
那个基本上看人都会心里有压迫
看人都不希望有这样的结局
所以
同学们将来如果有可能接触到这样的题材
记得最后的ending跟结尾要把所有的暴力拉回来
让他不那么的彻底失望
不那么的绝望
人类永远是战胜或者是正义和慈悲
永远站在最高的制高点
接着我们分享另外一首电玩的创作
大话巅峰
他的电玩叫大话西游
西游记很特别
这部明代的小说基本上就是奇幻世界
你想想看古代人写奇幻小说
你没办法联想吧
因为奇幻小说这样的词汇是现代人赋予的
但是创作的内容跟结构
西游记就具备了
就具备奇幻小说的所有的元素
他有孙悟空
沙悟净猪
八戒人可以变成猪
甚至于唐僧骑的那匹白马都是龙幻化而成的
想想看够奇幻吧
够丰富吧
所以这样子的一个奇幻世界的小说
不停地被翻拍成戏剧
不管是电影
电视甚至于电玩
因为我们的内心
对于这种奇幻世界的包容度是很大的
他就是奇幻世界吗
纵使他的奇幻世界就隐喻有批喻
讽刺当代的朝廷或当代的社会现况
但是看人听人读的人不介意
所以西游记这部章回小说
在中国的古代著作里面占有一席之地
而且这个一席之地几乎没有人能挑战
以现代人的眼光去看
它就是古代的奇幻小说
首先我们先进入主歌
云海汹涌
谁是屹立的松江水向东
名利皆被掏空
不需侵蚀撼动
我下笔从戎
挥毫入晴空
缘分如弓
这里面漂亮的句子是缘分如弓就是射出去
因为缘分要相遇嘛
所以缘分如公
然后这里面比较平庸的句子是我下笔从戎
就好像这个词汇很寻常
回到之前的课程
就是整段句子里面有精彩
有一般的组合
其实就够了
好第二大段
江山沉重
长安一片猩红
万里枯骨
成就几个英雄
每次有功成名就
朝代更迭的时候
大家都报道会著作的时候就会歌颂帝王
或是第一代开疆拓土的英雄
但是他在开疆拓土的时候
有多少士兵随着他征战而一去不回
一将功成万骨枯
就是这个道理好
接下来吾辈拒绝平庸
叹苍生不懂
叹西游江湖硝烟太浓
这里面用了两个碳
这个就是修辞学的一种
这样子的用法有好处
就是会累鸽子化
所有的类鸽子化就是会比较像你想象中的歌词
而不是堆积了很多华丽的句子
然后你一下子进不去他的时空
所以这种口语化的歌词有时候是很重要
也是关键
其
接下来进入副歌咯
大话巅峰
我忍身死痛
注意哦
副歌的第一行的第一句叫大话巅峰
它的歌名叫大话巅峰
这个是通俗的歌词中最主流
最字是最普遍的用法
就是副歌的第一句不是第一行哦
因为第一行有段落
歌词的第一句就变成歌的名字
这是最理所当然的使用形式
然后第二行是热血兄弟情义
钱是谁不忠
武林高手挥剑怒斩苦衷
红尘归来
痛饮中国风
大话巅峰
我逐天下梦
气吞山河的歌词
群雄逐鹿中原
大地被撼动
逐鹿中原嘛是常见的词汇
但是我把它拆开来使用
根据音乐的一个段落变成群雄逐鹿
中原大地被撼动
人间几回战斗
几回进攻几何
进宫去就很熟掉了
你知道吗
这句话就没有什么特别的漂亮
才能够在青史里光荣
这句话坦白说也很弱
但是没有关系
不需要每一个字
每一个段落都非常的崭新跟创意
那你创作也太辛苦了
不需要好
接下来我们进入第二遍的主歌
那因为创作这首歌的时候
时间还有
而且有时候觉得还不过瘾
印象还不够丰富
也因此他重复唱的时候的第二遍的主歌
我把歌词换掉了
旌旗烈烈
听呼啸的北风
面向苍穹关外的马蹄冲冲
我立誓的内容与黎明不同
寒夜敲冷钟
爱恨不动
寒夜哦还敲冷钟
钟
没有冷跟热巴就是加强他的意向
寒夜又敲能重
所以这种状况下爱恨不动
没有情绪
没有情绪才是最深沉的悲伤
创作就是这样子很多种变化跟选择
然后在这样一个电玩的主题曲的合作案中
有时候你会遇到很挑剔的甲方
但是没有关系
挑剔会让你成长
最怕的就是基本上没有任何要求你交稿
他就OK了
这样子也有坏处
就是它可能某种程度的觉得
说你教出的一定是好的作品
但你会自我要求
可是完完全全没有修改
好像哪里不对劲
你改个字
改个剧
就感觉上对方有开会有讨论
你还反而还心安
因为他有重视你的创作
面对这样的状况
有时候我反而开心
因为他们认真地在看待这次的作品跟专案
所谓嫌货才是买货人
知道吗
就是说你在买卖的过程中
你再开始哦
这个太贵了
这个东西好像哪里不对劲
诶这个人想要买咯
他才会去东挑西拣
那他们创作上开会开了好几次更改
我就觉得诶他们很重视
一旦重视
他们可能就花预算或行销上回去力推这首歌
音乐歌词创作的最终极目标就是有传唱度
有能见度
而不要说这个案子很小
然后创作上好好可以交稿了
然后他们也不行销
也不推广
然后问朋友也没听过
那你就懵了
因为你的窗已经燃烧一遍了
我最怕就是你熬尽脑汁交出去的创作不是工作
对方却放在非主打的歌
然后基本上也不去行销
也不去推广
也不重视
你就会很闷的
因为很多歌词的创意跟语法结构
甚至歌名只能用一次
你不能重复吗
但是你这么真心对待
这么慎重的一个作品
却没有得到应有的能见度和曝光度
你就会觉得很吃亏
早知道这首好作品就不要交出去
不要给这个方案用
也因此呢各位同学记得
假设你有一个合作案
对方叫你改来改去啊
然后哪边要调整呢
千万有耐心
这代表他们很重视
他们想要最好的状况
最好的词曲跟配套的组合去面对市场
有时候我还遇过换歌手的诶
这个歌手的vocal或者是他的音色不搭
这次的专案还换歌手
当这种例子很罕见
但曾经就是遇过
你应该把创作当做生活
那生活上会遇到晴天
会遇到雨天
遇到塞车
会遇到刚好排队买不到想要的餐点
那遇到的这些生活的琐事呢
就回到创作上
遇到各种的要求和挑剔
就好像生活上会遇到的一些困难
那如果说会遇到这些困难
就是恭喜你
代表你已经进来这个圈子了